how is Africa mate I mean how has it
been made to mean and what is associated
with this idea of a freaking I mean it's
weird to talk about it as this one plays
that's exactly the point how is it that
we've come to talk about Africa as a
thing a place in the world when in fact
you know it includes 50 over 50
countries thousands of languages
millions of people right today in the
podcast a conversation about teaching a
categorically misunderstood concept
Africa
our guest today found inspiration for
bold new ways of teaching through her
own experiences as a student she
recognized throughout her education the
ability for teachers to empower or
inhibit their students what's made the
biggest difference for me in the
classroom as a student has been
instructors who made me feel like I had
something to offer and the lack of that
does a lot of damage me when have having
instructors and make you feel like you
have nothing to offer it that's actually
damaging it's not just neutralized
damaging so it's really important for me
to sort of valorized students voices and
to show them that they're doing it
welcome to chalk radio a podcast about
inspired teaching at MIT
I'm your host Sarah Hansen from MIT
OpenCourseWare in this episode I take
you with me to meet Amma Edo an
assistant professor of African Studies
at MIT professor Eidos research centers
around the complex array of cultures
traditions nations and ideas known as
Africa and how Africa as a concept is
produced through material practices
things like music ritual performance and
dress will learn how she engages
students in unpacking the concept of
Africa through the very creative
practices that make it so what does it
look like to challenge the meaning we've
prescribed to a place as rich and
diverse as Africa we'll pick up our
conversation with professor Eddowes
explanation you know we were used to
speaking of Africa as a place and not
just any place but a place that's
burdened with
a lot of ideas and values that
historically have been negative to put
it simply and so what my research and my
teaching centers on is about
interrogating that so first making
visible the ways that Africa is made to
mean so that's what I mean with Africa
as a category of thought to understand
that Africa means more than just this
geographical space you know it's also
all these countries and all this is very
complicated history but then to see the
ways that this valence that Africa
quote-unquote has the way that that
plays out in all aspects of life really
so broadly speaking this is like this
question of thinking about Africa's
category of thought is understanding the
politics that are involved in engaging
with the continent and an intellectual
man or politically and so on in this
course we use creative practices the
arts popular culture as a way in for two
reasons one because there's a way that
you know I don't I'm not crazy about the
term popular culture because it's a way
that it seems to devalue it and it's
just you know kind of fun yet it
animates so much of our daily
experiences no matter who you are in no
matter where you are in the world so on
one hand the purpose of their goal of
using this as a way into asking these
more kind of theoretical and
philosophical questions about Africa as
a category of thought is to recognize
that these everyday practices are
actually extremely rich and extremely
and just as political as any other form
of engagement but then more specifically
to Africa is the fact that right now you
know Africa is sort of having this
moment where it's signification is
appearing to shift part of is
understanding whether it's actually
shifting but we're you know this all the
stories we had about the continent used
to be about war and disease and famine
and dysfunction simply speaking now
there's also another discourse where
Africa is hot
Africa is sort of the future Africa is
where all of these new possibilities are
playing out so whether it's or within
the the business realm or it's or within
the arts or that's this idea that Africa
is the last frontier so there's a way
that Africa's
got a new prominence on the global stage
and that a lot of that is playing out in
the realm of what I call creative
practice so the arts and popular culture
and that's why it's I thought that it
would be a particularly good angle to
take in addressing these sort of lofty
or questions and seeing the ways that
they play out in the day-to-day and also
through beautiful and pleasant objects
and pleasant things to engage with
things that are moving and that are
inspiring which i think opens us up to
to thinking and to processing
differently when we moved in this other
this other way it makes me wonder how
this specific case of looking at Africa
as a category of thought and looking at
creative practices like did it open for
students new ways of seeing the world in
general like does this kind of teaching
offer new pathways for critical thinking
that's applicable in many fields I'd
hope so I mean my god that's like that's
our dream as educators right that
anything that whatever we do in the
classroom and it's very limited setting
or in this limited scale manifests or
for our students that they're able to
take it into their experiences way
beyond the classroom and beyond the
specific topic of the course when I
think about the students that I had in
the class last year it was about 12
students and about half of them were
African or of so Africans of different
varieties so Africans from the continent
Africans were first-generation Americans
and then the other half were American of
varying ethnicities and I would say that
for all of them is well certainly for my
African students it was a way that they
I think it's safe to say we're kind of
weren't there because they were
interested in engaging with this part of
their experience in a different realm to
actually study it in the classroom
instead of it just being kind of what
they are immersed in and their
day-to-day lives in their back home and
so on and for the non African students
some of them were going to be working on
in Africa on this during the summer or
had just come back from being on the
continent and just wanted to kind of
learn more general
about the continent so so what extent
did being in the class broaden their
perspectives or kind of give them tools
that they could use beyond the specific
topic after the class I think the class
might have helped them get language for
to articulate some of these questions
about power essentially and if not
always to find answers to at least be
able to notice patterns and and sort of
describe what they're seeing so often
you know we have a feeling that
something's all right or that there's
something going on here but we don't
quite have the language for it and I
think that that's what a class like this
aims to do is to give students language
to articulate these things that they
might be picking up on in different ways
so what does it look like to empower
students to follow a feeling to develop
the language to negotiate that feeling
into theory so we met once a week and we
focus each session on a different form
of cultural production um or a different
theme so we had performance and then
within performance your performance as
stress and then we had literature and we
had film and we had what a science and
technology and so for each unit new
questions came up but the thread I cut
across them was the same I which was a
question of how is Africa being made to
mean in the world and how our African
cultural producers engaging in that
process of making Africa I mean through
their practice and of course and the
questions that come up about are like
what are the specific issues that arise
with this particular form of cultural
production right so for theatre what
does it mean for instance to produce a
play for an audience in Nigeria to come
perform that play in Cambridge
Massachusetts what are the politics and
that what are the questions that come up
in carrying this object from one space
into the next the goal was to both
reflect through each of these cases this
underlying question that the course was
after but then to show the nuances or
the specificities that
apply to each particular form of
creative production and then ultimately
to say you know what do we gain by Chuck
supposing these different things is
there you know what can we learn about
ideas of technological innovation in or
for the continent by looking at them
alongside the production of photographer
ethnographic portraits in the 19th
century in South Africa for instance is
there a way that these two cases can
elucidate one another and I think yes I
mean there's a reason that you know I
did it that way but yeah and I think
that you know there was also another
agenda behind it is that being at MIT in
particular where we tend to fetishize
technology and and consider it sometimes
in the realm outside of other material
practices other ways of knowing and of
my personal one of my personal missions
is to show that you know it's no
different there's just different they're
all objects they're all ways of doing
they're all ways of knowing right so
whether we're talking about plant
healing or developing the next nano
whatever we can think about these things
next to each other no matter where
they're happening and so I think the
ways that case studies are useful is
that they allow you to both kind of dig
deep for that particular situation bring
questions to the fore and then next time
kind of consider the ways that those
questions can apply or when new
questions arise when you look at a
different situation
you mentioned performance and could you
speak a little bit about how students
attended performances out in the world
as part of this course yeah you know so
that kind of has to happen
serendipitously um it just so happened
to be that at the time that I was
teaching this class this show came was I
don't even remember how I found out
about it I think from a mailing list or
a friend told me I don't know that this
display was coming to um to Harvard and
similarly that Alan goomy's was gonna be
coming to to Harvard also and I had so
in the case of Van Gogh me
just seen his film at a conference a few
months before one of his films and
absolutely adored it and so I'd wanted
to teach it and it was an amazing
opportunity to have them here and you
know so that because you would also be
speaking about the film and so in both
cases it was an opportunity I saw these
outings as an opportunity for students
to UM to engage with these materials
sort of in a more social way so it's one
thing to be in your room and to just
watch a film on your laptop it's a
different thing to be an auditorium with
various kinds of people to kind of pick
up on the energy that's around you how
people have other people around you are
responding to different parts of the
film right that's part of the experience
also not to mention that to hear the
filmmaker tell you what they were
thinking when they created this thing
right how other audiences responded to
it and so on and then of course just the
experience of leaving MIT I think it's
really useful like I remember when I was
an undergrad you know Harvard seems far
as I think part of our duty is as
educators also is to you know help
broaden our students horizons both in
the classroom but also by encouraging
them to just go explore beyond campus
professor ed o also has a unique way of
broadening students horizons within the
classroom as well by reshaping their
relationship with academic texts all
part of an intentional process to
eradicate the barrier placed between
academic work and life so when I you
know I've been I was a student for a
very long time and I was very frequently
frustrated by the fact that academic
texts often feel like they're written to
not be understood and this made me
really angry because you know when I was
in grad school for my PhD I thought okay
I've been in school for many years how
is it that this still makes no sense
right it makes no sense to me like how
you know what what are we doing here
right what is the point of the academic
enterprise if we produce work that can
be understood
so this has been a gripe of mine for a
very long time and and and it was all
the more frustrating when there was no
space to express that right because I
think the danger when you're a student
often time especially you know at elite
institutions is that you internalize
these like when you don't understand you
think there's something wrong with you
essentially you're not good enough
you're not smart enough when it's a
structural issue and it's actually on
the readers on the writers to write
better or write better work write more
clearly so then that requires I think an
infrastructure to support students in
processing this often opaque work and to
me that's how I was thinking about the
reading responses so as a way to just
when you're forced to sit down and write
something about what you wrote even if
it's just like I don't understand and
these are all the questions that are
coming up for me it already pushes you
along like kind of your understanding
for yourself and then also gives me as
the instructor a way to know where
you're at and you know what I need to
bring to the just kind of in the
classroom discussion so what I asked her
to do was to try to summarize the key
points of the argument and then they
were free to take it in any number of
directions it could either relate it to
other work that we've read in class they
could relate it to stuff in the news
that they're seeing around it they could
relate it seeing around them and kind of
use what was coming up in the readings
as a way to make sense of these things
they were observing around them or kind
of related to their personal experience
something going on in their own lives or
you know and the what I wanted to do
there was again to to show that what we
do in the classroom is not separate
academic work isn't separate from life
right like it's not and it's not
something that's only accessible to some
people right we are always theorizing
when we make some making sense of our
experience is about theorizing and so to
offer possibilities for students to make
these links between what they're reading
for school and what they're experiencing
in the world around them if we can do
that I think you know we're in great
shape as educators I really love you
know being able to point to something
that they've said in making my argument
right so or in presenting my lesson so
if I can say yeah as you brought up in
your paper this thing is going on in the
reading that's exactly right and we also
see you know so it to show that
when I'm taking their work seriously
right and also that they have something
to offer to me I think right what's made
the biggest difference for me in the
classroom as a student has been
instructors who made me feel like I had
something to offer and and you know and
the the the lack of that does a lot of
damage you might have having instructors
and make you feel like you have nothing
to offer it that's actually damaging
it's not just neutralized damaging so
it's really important for me to sort of
valorize students voices and to show
them that they're doing in part of why
we wanted to profile professor Eidos
teaching of her global Africa class was
her willingness to try things in the
classroom that were new to her such as
inviting students to participate in
creative production this approach
culminated in a final project assignment
that had to say the least
exceeded expectations in the final
project assignment students were asked
to examine how Africa's place in the
world is negotiated through creative
production what kind of challenges did
students take on in this work my poor
students how many more students because
this is an experiment I thought it'd be
really cool I mean it seemed you know it
seemed like the right thing in the
course we're looking at people who are
making creative work doing creative work
in different arenas it seemed like the
right way to culminates as students to
do the same himself and yeah I had no
idea how it turned out because I didn't
know what they were bringing to the
table if they you know what particular
skills they had I creative skills but I
want to believe this is something I I
try to enact in my own life that we all
have creative skills and so whatever you
have we can do something with it and
they were you know blessing because they
were game for the experiment because I
had done this if I didn't know how it
was how it was going to go but I I asked
them to pick a topic that they were
interested in either something we'd
already talked about in class that they
wanted to take farther or another
another topic altogether and the key was
to use this object this thing that they
would make as a way to think through
these questions about Africa
based in the world it's quite broad but
I was so happy with the things they came
up with you know I was wonderful it was
so fun we had anything from like it was
no student who was interested in plants
and she picked this plant one of these
eye things like the ficus plant some
plant that's really sexy right now in
like the interior decoration decorating
world and it's a plant that grows on the
side of the street in West Africa and so
on and so she did this cool project or
she took the plan and looked at the
different ways that it is made to mean
as a kind of luxury decoration item and
verses in central Africa where it's used
for Africa like some part of the tree is
used for bark cloth and so from there so
you could talk about the circulation of
objects in a way that value gets our
thinking and so on or other students who
wanted to talk about the way that
tradition that's kind of yeah related
the way that tradition gets articulated
and they were interested in looking at
wedding ceremonies in them not in
Nigerian American sort of in the
Nigerian American context where people
are kind of working across these
different cultures these two different
cultural realms and to consider you know
what do you keep of a tradition what do
you update what does it mean to treat
women a particular way and men a
particular way which what should you
uphold what should you you know resists
given you know when you're a Nigerian
American and you're kind of beholden or
you belong to these two different
cultures and so what they did which I
thought was so brilliant was that they
put together a picture book because we'd
also one of the classes had talked about
these photo novels as a genre of image
and story telling image production and
storytelling and so they use that format
that we talked about it in the class and
took the theme that they were interested
in arounds or the politics of tradition
and in ebo weddings and wrote a story
that featured them grappling with these
questions so it was quite meta because
they told you you know they talked about
the the topic they were interested in
but then they also showed you the
questions that they brought up it wasn't
a resolved
thing and it was meant to be circulated
and it was an object that could be used
to spur questions and so on and so it
was fantastic I loved I so enjoyed them
there was something we had a coffee
ceremony in class like in the Philippine
coffee ceremony and the sort of
questions that brings up about what does
it take to actually and act what the
ceremony is is supposed to enact when
you take it out of Ethiopia and when you
take it into a dorm room for instance
and you only have certain implements to
use to what extent you know does it
retain its value its significance but it
was wonderful to see them start happy
like oh my god I have no idea what I'm
gonna do and then just figuring it out
and coming up with something amazing we
actually have the example of the wedding
conflict book on the OCW website we've
linked to it in the show notes so be
sure to take a look to close our
conversation I wanted to see what advice
Alma has for other educators looking to
employ some of her techniques in their
classes what are her strategies for
keeping her class engaging thoughtful
and illuminating so one key thing is
being clear on what the core issue is in
the class right so what's the core
what's the question that animates this
class and for me it's useful to kind of
know that and have that because that
helps me sort of adjust that's needed so
I so to figure out okay what do I need
what do i what do I want these students
to come away with no matter what so that
if what I have planned is not taking us
there then I can try something else that
might get us there so being clear on
this question so for this class you know
global Africa creative culture is the
idea was to examine Africa's place in
the world as as being made visible
through different kinds of creative
practice so I structured it according to
things that I was familiar with from my
work or interested in and that I wanted
to explore more so that's one way to to
go about deciding what the different
units are going to be right so I'm I'm
interested in dress for instance and so
performance as dress was something that
was really into doing so the pieces of
the class can be completely different
they can focus on different kind of
creative practices you can spend more
than one week on a particular creative
practice right so the
building blocks can be different and as
long as a core question is as clear then
you can sort of tailor that to your
interest but then also to what's
available what's cool about the notion
of kind of creative practice is that
it's very broad like it can be as broad
as you want it to be so it can be
restructured you know any number of ways
depending on the resources that are
available and the questions that you are
used or your students are interested in
and tied to that is the fact that as
someone told me a colleague told me once
that we're talking about you know
first-year faculty and we're both
talking about how exhausted we were all
the time and she said someone told her
you know that teaching is essentially
like stand-up or improv right like you
get up there and you're on and it's
improv because you are responding to
what your students are giving you and
you have no idea what it's going to be
no matter how well planned it is you
have no idea where it might end up and
you have to respond so it's not just
that you they're taking it but you have
based on what you're getting you have to
figure out where to take it in order to
come back to the conclusions that you
think you need to and that and also be
open to that not happening and when
you're new you just you don't know and
when you've been a student and you've
had these professors up front who seem
to know exactly what they're doing what
they're talking about
you don't fully appreciate the fact that
it's a lot of intuitive and
improvisational work and so you can be
surprised at how taxing it is you know
so at the end of a three hour class I
mean that was wasted oh you know you
just you just so tired because it
requires so much energy so that's
something to just kind of be aware of
which also then can inform you like
inform your preparation so to know what
do you need to do in order to have as
much no to stock up to fill up your tank
so that you can then do this through our
improv performance and you know
generally the less tightly designed it
is the better things work out this is
what I found and what I've heard other
colleagues say that you know the days
went they were running from meeting to
meeting and they didn't quite have
enough time to finish their course prep
or actually the days where the class
went really well because
they had no choice but to be there and
listen to the students and meet them
where they were and follow that organic
progression of the conversation instead
of sticking to their script yeah so I
think you know the key pieces of advice
I would give are kind of one flexibility
both in sort of the approach to teaching
and recognizing the flexibility that you
have in designing the course and
choosing what you put in it and then and
and tie to this flexibility this
experimental approach to building it and
to adjusting it as it goes and then as a
broader kind of like teaching philosophy
thing what I said about using the time
in the classroom as a time to build our
students confidence right to instill in
our students a sense that they know like
they they are capable of doing this work
to validate to affirm and to use that as
a starting point for what it is that we
want to impart onto them you know but
really to start from to kind of undo
some of the damage that academic work
has done for so many people which is
that its alienating and so - to try to
see how to make it less alienating - to
say you know we can do this and we we
know how to do this and we're learning
and it's okay to not know because we're
in school to learn not supposed to know
everything that we come here to make
that as part of the mission beyond both
beyond the content of the class itself
to just say it's okay to not know and to
not know this particular material but we
know how to learn and that's what we're
here for
amah ido is an assistant professor of
African Studies at MIT and now you can
follow her work wherever you are in the
world in the show notes we've posted a
link to our faculty page which includes
more information about her research
background and scholarly works as a
bonus we're also giving you a link to
the Spotify playlist that one of our
students created for the class it is
fantastic
go take a listen also in our show notes
you'll find a link to Emma's Go Lobel
Africa course on MIT OpenCourseWare for
those of you who might be new to the OCW
website you'll find virtually all of MIT
s course content for you to explore if
you're an educator build curricula of
any kind or just plain curious please
take a look we are dedicated to making
access to all of mi t--'s course content
free and open for the world visit us at
ocw.mit.edu in this podcast we'll be
sharing our conversations with some of
the amazing MIT educators who've helped
populate OCW and whose work has been
shared thousands of times from our site
thanks for listening and please stay
tuned
in the meantime share this episode with
a friend or leave a review on iTunes
[Music]